mammograms as we all know can save lives
but CBS News has learned in some cases
insurance companies are refusing to
cover them we first looked back into
this in October for a series medical
price roulette it's a collaboration with
clear health cost and after that story
aired we heard from hundreds of women
including some who got surprise bills
for hundreds of dollars our consumer
investigative correspondent Anna Warner
is following all of this and a good
morning to you what did you learn what'd
you find out
yeah that's right Gail hundreds of women
wrote to tell us they could not afford
the follow-up tests their doctors had
ordered like additional mammograms
ultrasounds and MRIs we even heard this
from women who survived breast cancer
like the one in Pennsylvania you're
about to meet Rosie and Neil fought
breast cancer and won but this 52
year-old single mom says for the past
year she's been fighting her insurance
company and losing I felt that I was
being penalized for having breast cancer
the cancer occurred in 2015
since then she's had annual diagnostic
mammograms paid for by her insurance
then last year she switched jobs and in
October I went in got the mammogram and
then about a month later I got a bill
for over $900 over $900 $900 her
insurance company Aetna had refused to
pay they said no that we don't cover
diagnostic mammograms I said but I had
breast cancer why wouldn't you cover
this if I had breast cancer
the Affordable Care Act requires
insurance companies to pay for regular
screening mammograms for women with no
out-of-pocket costs but because she's a
breast cancer survivor Neal says her
doctor told her she needed what's called
a diagnostic mammogram a similar test
that's read more quickly every year for
five years after her cancer treatment so
Neal appealed to Aetna you literally
told the insurance company I do not feel
it is fair to be penalized for having
had breast cancer yes and I told them
that verbally and again when I told them
verbally there was no response we're
just not going to pay this so there was
no negotiation there was no discussion
there was no
argument it was this is the way it is
have a nice day in this letter Aetna
told Neil her claim was processed
correctly that Aetna does not consider
this specific test as part of the
standard routine testing how do you feel
about that angry very angry I feel that
it's very unfair that someone who has
had breast cancer who is following the
protocol that the doctor is prescribing
is not being covered for preventive
maintenance really Neil is one of
hundreds of women who have shared their
mammogram pricing stories with CBS News
one wrote she feels punished for being a
survivor because of the astronomical
costs another said she skipped her
mammogram this year saying I cannot
afford to have this happen again it's
really creating a significant barrier to
care Molly Guthrie is with the Susan G
Komen Foundation which is pushing
lawmakers to get all breast cancer
screening tests covered we want the
diagnostic testing that of physician
feels their patient should have that the
patient can have access to that without
cost-sharing
without any cost to the patient so that
means diagnostic mammogram ultrasound
MRI mm-hmm any of those rights so far
bills have passed in five states we've
seen women discriminated against for a
long time in health care congresswoman
Debbie Dingell is co-sponsoring federal
legislation in the house but so far
there are no Senate sponsors we need to
make sure that every woman has access to
the tests she needs to know if she's got
breast cancer as for Neil's
over $900 bill after CBS News contacted
Aetna to ask about her case it reversed
course saying we mistakenly did not
apply the appropriate policy when Ms
Neil appealed we apologize for this
mistake Neil says she doesn't believe it
so why do you think they do it greed you
know the money it's all about money the
bottom line
Aetna told us it will now reprocess
Neil's claim and reimburse her for any
out-of-pocket costs we asked whether any
other
women were affected by that mistake but
we're told no that Aetna believes this
is an isolated issue but if you have a
story to tell us about Aetna mammograms
or other medical prices any of them go
to CBS news.com slash slash health costs
or email us at health costs at CBS
news.com we want to hear you're such a
great series and it clearly pays to to
to raise the issue yes because how many
times do these come reason you hear at
the end oh now the insurance company is
coming to the table she says she
appealed actually three times through
three levels of eight times and company
HR department even went to them so you
know after we contacted them now it's a
mistake but her pursuing it on her own
didn't work that's why she she doesn't
believe what they're saying that's
frustrating you pay and pay and failure
insurance bills and then when you need
them there's fifty million reasons why
they can't help you I'm glad they took
another look after a call all right Anna
thank you very much